let's talk about the November election
but not about Trump and Hillary okay
let's talk about marijuana legalization
which is on the ballot in five states on
November 8th and currently as of right
now the yes to legalization side is
leading in all five states although in
some states not really by huge margins
anything could happen on November 8th
but let's look at where the polling is
now in these five states starting with
Arizona Arizona currently 50% support
legalization forty percent opposed
in California support is ahead of
opposed fifty two to forty one in
Massachusetts it's fifty three to forty
supporting legalization of marijuana in
Maine it's fifty three to thirty eight
supporting and in Nevada not Nevada I
now pronounce it correctly Nevada
57 to thirty three in favor of
legalization there is literally no
serious argument anymore for making
marijuana use a criminal offense we've
had forty years of the war on drugs it's
done nothing positive it's done so much
negative I will be voting for
legalization here in Massachusetts
despite having absolutely no plans to
start smoking pot if yes wins
I mean Rachael Pat are either of you
even conflicted about how to vote on
this for me it's pretty clear well yeah
I'm voting YES for sure and I think it's
seen an increase in support because the
oldest generation the so-called Silent
Generation yeah at this point is kind of
dying off yeah and there's a politically
correct way to say it is they're aging
out of the electorate they're aging out
of the electorate there's kind of this
consolidation between like the baby
boomers yeah who are young during the
sixties and seventies and now people who
are young now Millennials and they're
they're all for it
so a yes vote from Pat I am voting YES
on this in Massachusetts Rachel yeah I
mean I'm voting YES but I just think
that a lot of people seem also really
frustrated by the lack of discussion
kind of going on with the candidates
because they can obviously say okay it's
left up to state devices but what about
the tax code and federal federal banking
regulations right not going to change so
if there's state
businesses they can be free to sell
their marijuana and they're not going to
be prosecuted so those are the questions
that I would ask but I so I guess I
understand that that frustration there
yeah really this is becoming here's my
prediction okay we like with gay
marriage which started with
Massachusetts standing alone and then
eventually a couple of other states
trickled in and then eventually it was
an avalanche and before we got to 50 out
of 50 the Supreme Court said bans on
same-sex marriage are unconstitutional
we're not going to see I I don't think
any Supreme Court decision that will
legalize marijuana around the u.s.
because there's no constitutional right
to smoke weed right but we are seeing
now Colorado Washington we're seeing a
couple of states trickle in we are
starting to see that this is not a bad
thing it's not World War three breaking
out it's not everything's falling off
the walls and and infrastructure is
crumbling and we are going to see an
acceleration if three out of the five
states that are voting on this in
November end up voting yes you're going
to see an acceleration the problem is
that we still see marijuana as a
schedule 1 drug at the federal level it
is still illegal recreationally at the
federal level and depending on who is
president the president could decide
that feds should ignore state laws about
marijuana and still go after individuals
based on federal law that's something
that could happen you could have a
president who takes a much more
aggressive approach at this within the
States based on what federal law is I
see that ultimately we are going to see
many many states legalize marijuana and
this is also going to loosen research
regulations etc but if anybody's waiting
for some Supreme Court decision like we
saw with gay marriage it's probably not
going to happen so what rachel is
bringing up are all really good points
the banking issue is a big thing many
people don't know this but because it is
difficult to have a bank account if your
business is the selling of marijuana
either retail or a grow operation or
whatever even if it's legal at the state
level a lot of these marijuana
dispensaries are dealing exclusively in
cash
what does that mean number one they
become targets for theft and robbery
number two they have to spend a whole
bunch of money on security and
everything that comes with having
security at your location number three
they've got to spend money on expensive
safes and a whole process for getting
this money stored and and how do you
manage all of this cash I mean it's
really a nightmare and this is exactly
what rachel is getting at here a big
picture schedule one is a disaster
criminalization and putting people in
jail for marijuana use is a disaster
restricting research on medicinal
benefits is also a disaster and what
what we do need to continue focusing on
is telling the stories of Colorado
telling the stories of Washington and of
other countries that have decriminalized
and even legalized marijuana
nothing insane has happened that's it I
mean I don't know I don't know how else
to tell you what's not to like do either
of you even know anybody who is voting
no on this in Massachusetts I do but I'm
not going to say who they are well no
you don't have to say who but can you
tell us why they're voting now I had you
know what tell us who they are why not I
think I know I'm kidding no but what's
the argument they may not going to put
them on blast I just think it's a
conservative view about substances in
general and I think that their kind of
argument is scant in any data that would
support what they're saying do they
support cigarettes or alcohol being
banned as well
no and both of these people don't drink
okay but but I'm but they don't they're
not saying that alcohol should be
illegal I know I don't think that
alcohol should be illegal but I don't
think that they would be in support of
any laws that are saying lowering any
age anything of that nature all right
well so Rachel know someone that's
interesting I probably could think of a
couple people that I know although I
haven't talked to them about it but no
one that no one that's willing to
mention it says that they're voting no
here in Massachusetts Gamefly is sort of
like Netflix for video games they have
over 8,000 new and classic games for
xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDP s the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the David
Pakman show audience and support our
show by going to Gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s